Let's go next to our caller from the [inaudible]
who's calling today from two one four.
It's from two wonderful Oh David.
Is that made
it is
is.
Um, David, I had some, uh, thoughts about
the, um, super title against situation.
Is there any way that this is going to positively
impact Bernie?
Cause I know it's not going to, and is there
any way we can like fix this super delicate
issue cause I think they're really gonna negatively
impact Bernie.
Well there's already been some changes.
All right lesson that I just, you've got me
on a five second delay on it.
So we're just going to do away with that.
Listen there, the DNC has made changes to
the way that super delegates will work.
They're not going to vote on the first round
we've already gone through.
Is there a way in which it could still hurt
Bernie?
Um, yes, it is conceivable.
Is there a way it could hurt a different candidate
is also conceivable.
But the whole point of the changes supposedly
was to give the people more of a chance to
just decide outright on the first ballot.
The question is, if it goes to a second ballot,
then what is going to happen in terms of the
superdelegate impact?